all right George yes sir George uh
where'd you grow up where you from
originally I originally grew up in
belflower uh belflower is my my hometown
suburb of La tell tell me about your
family growing up uh dad passed away
when I was three from heroin
uh step Ste that he stepped in real
quick uh very quiet man hardworking we
never ever ever ever really spoke my mom
I love her dearly uh she had her hard
life and she was kind of abusive though
too
uh I grew up in environments where I had
to fight the other kids in the
neighborhood for no reason it's like at
a four like being at four five six years
old uh always had to be on my own cuz my
mom and my stepdad were always working
so I never had nobody there to
vent
never had nobody to vent to never never
told my mom that I was getting fights or
getting beat up all the time by The
Neighborhood kids and
[__] at such a young
age I would have to get
up during Middle School right to clean
the whole house before I went to school
my mom would be gone my stepdad would be
gone but I would have to clean the whole
house I started working at the age of 13
uh fixing the U cutting the neighbor's
Lawns uh
I I I think um I I tried religion when I
was 16 I I became a disciple got real
deep in religion
but I lost a friend from breast
cancer and then I my friend Richard he
he died he got shot in the neck when he
was just 18 he was a drummer for our
band that we
made uh that that broke us it it kind of
sounds like a movie but that was it was
that was that was our
life he he was a he was a cool kid you
know
but wrong place at the wrong
time
um my mom and me my my stepdad didn't
really ever ever get
along I love them still but I got kicked
out or I left when I was 16 years
old I started Living in people's like
garages at first but it didn't last no
more than a few months and then I went
to the rear bed cuz I didn't know where
else to go cuz in belflower usually you
can't be out on the curb or by the store
or in front of the liquor
store I
uh I had to learn how to adjust and I
was I was always by myself cuz I was a
new kid on the in the streets or in in
the riverbed or just any other like
homeless Community would not accept me
cuz I
was I'm not sure why they never accepted
me is it was so hard
I've
been stomped out chased away beat up
just for sitting down and just being
myself sometimes but I I'm pretty sure
there's something I was doing wrong that
just wasn't right I know I have this
certain
look my eyes like maybe for me I feel
like my my my my my uh self-esteem says
is my eyes
good I got beat up a lot as a kid I mean
it's is less
trauma but then later on in life as I
got older I uh I tried going to college
I but I and it wasn't working out I felt
stupid I
felt unworthy and I think it just kind
of felt like it came from my the the
lack of love
but my
heart my heart is
just lost confusing I was trying to
prove to myself and to other people that
I I can fit and I could be that this
cool kid and I I I can do these bad
things too you know I I can shop
shoplift with you I I yeah I'm I'm down
to do drugs with you first time I did uh
drugs I was 17 with marijuana then at 18
I started doing
methamphet for methamphet
uh very quickly the first people that I
met that did
methamphetamine for people that been on
meth for about 50 years I mean like old
cats older cats in belflower I'm like
and then I met their friends and their
friends and they're like Heavy Hitters
like in that in the city and it's just
like and like the type people you got
you got to really respect be nice and
respectful towards or they're going to
they would [__] me up or they
they and I and me did I always did what
they said that people pleasing thing and
[__] now at this age is different but
then I met so many people from all types
of races all types of
places my friends my my friends were
like well conservative drug
dealers I mean you would never think
that they were drug dealers because my
friends were mostly
Caucasian and and kept their house and
stuff like that and like they were real
clean about
it and for some reason they took me in
because
of maybe guilt or maybe they thought I'm
not too bad of a person and stuff you
know or maybe they could just take
advantage the fact that I could go out
they could stay home and I could sell
nickels and dimes and
whatnot
um I've seen
people I've seen bodies burnt a body
burnt in comp by by compon I walked by
it was just there he like I don't I
don't know who did it don't care who did
it I don't care why he got killed and
[__] was just I was just trying to find
a spot to like sleep and it
just my my my mind is like well what the
[__] happened to you but in reality like
which
human sees a dead body that's completely
burnt charred down like like like like a
steak like a ruined [__] steak all
over the side of his face what bright
human stands there and just keeps
smoking just cuz he doesn't want to go
anywhere else cuz too lazy to go
somewhere
else and then I didn't think it's going
to affect me later
on it became a it started becoming a
cycle like a repetitive thing I started
finding like ended up in weird
situations where
uh whether the crowd might believe me or
not when I lived in Coachella I cuz I
had moved to Coachella I've been in
Coachella India I've been I've been in
Arizona I've been in
Nevada but went
Cella so I'm jumping a little forward
but I caught some cases two
assaults and that's either way I some
stuff that got real deep in Riverside
County and I had to go and live in ride
County while I was on probation and
parole for the second
one
I once I completed the program of course
the whole story of me leaving my mom
house since I was 16 I had nowhere to go
after I completed the program or the the
rehab and then I I would become homeless
again I became homeless in Coachella for
two
years and super super hot
weather and very I ended up being around
very very mean people I mean
like my man my friend my friend he's
like I said he like yeah I'm putting a
body in the in in the suitcase I like
okay cool I like shut
up I walk in the [__]
room I don't see [__] but I I
but I feel like I I feel like I want to
lie cuz it's on camera I'm lying I
didn't see [__]
but I was scared to him but then I
wanted to prove to
him and I wanted to prove to people in
over there in that City I was like I
ain't no punk I ain't no
[__] now it's different now I'll walk
away real quick I'm try to diffuse it or
like understand that they had a rough
life and then they're probably having a
bad
day the toughest part is later on
because sometimes I wasn't I I I try to
get away from that the hustle with my
home girl sell selling I mean larger
amounts of methan sitting in belflower
and in Lake with
toos having to like decent like
regular Society B abiding like families
like and just like these people that you
would never think they use
meth
I would get pulled over by people
randomly and say hey can I do this for
you can I can I can I pay you for me to
touch you and I'm like At first I like
[__] off [__] off just buy me something
to eat can't you just buy me something
to eat like no not listen you let me
touch you and
[__] then one day I got real hungry
really hungry I started getting really
skinny I got desperate I I started
crying this guyy started getting me
touching me giving me head and I was
like I felt so [__] I started crying
as giving me head and [__] he didn't
care the fact that it wasn't even going
up but I was hungry and I I like think
about I was that I was
hungry I'm not proud of Moy I'm not
proud that I be started doing that I was
not educated
right I
didn't I left the home early and say
like and I thought that I knew
everything and I didn't know [__] I
didn't know squat I still don't know
squat it got so [__] hard dude it's
like but then it got a little easy and I
got kind of a little normal to it it got
it got a little normal I got
desensitized to uh having sex with male
female didn't matter now it's like I
tried being in a relationship
right with the mother and my kids we
were together for8 years but when it
comes to sex I
don't my body my feelings there there's
no connection there's no connection
there's any type of relationships there
will be no connection with a female or
male there's it's just like a going to
work it's just work now it's
just and me dealing with drugs and stuff
like that PCP and doing cavy
I used to be a heroin addict
too I mean I'm a Slammer I I do syringes
it was just I was I was slamming about
four or five times a day about 40 units
no
problem and
uh it got to the point where
uh I'd be so high that I would have the
certain look
like hey who do you think you are and
I'll be like no no nobody and I be like
why you [__] mad dogging me I'm not
mad doging you sir and I would look in
the mirror and they
like holy [__] I my eyes would be
completely black I'm like I'm not I'm
not I'm not trying to Mad Dog you
seriously
like but then as those moments kept
going like I would meet randomly and it
would happen repetitively like God was
like going to pick at me the whole
time I'm 37 right
now this [__] started when I was
like about 20 years
old people wanted test me I don't know
why I think that's is it a male thing a
male Eagle is it a the the Primal
[__] just feeling of a man that we
have to [__] punk or bully somebody I
don't know what I don't I don't do it or
try to feel like you're above that
person or you're in control of that room
or the people that are in the
room I'm the type of person that you
could take charge I don't care I'm I'm
kind of lazy about doing all
that if this how you want to ruin run
the room then that's how we're going to
run the room and [__] I care less and
[__] I just want to [__] be able to
make my day pass
on I've been beat had my jaw broken in
five places had my tongue split to the
side for just walking up and down Long
Long Beach North Side Long
Beach that that really affected me the
fact that I was just a
Mexican cuz I was
Mexican I've heard of racism I I know
the history
of but I love the fact that I am not
racist not no [__] I'm not lying to
nobody this between me and I guess I see
you in the back of the camera but
it's bro I've been bullied all my life
when I got I've been they stab me my
they stabbed me in my jugy record with
the ice
piig with the ice piig just CU was
[__]
annoying my self-esteem went
down because I was thinking maybe I am
annoying maybe I am stupid maybe I'm
[__] maybe I am making wrong
moves but then it's like
I'm jumping around my stories and I'm
trying to because I'm like I want to be
known that I'm trying to tell the
truth I'm broken I'm broken I I'm a I'm
a crazy
cutter I mean instead of hurting people
now I cut when you piss me off I'mma
walk away and I'm a
cut I'm sorry but I refuse to go back to
prison I'm I'm not the one that's going
to be I don't give a [__] I'll go back
you know what I'm a real one and I'm
going tell you I don't want to go back I
don't want to prove nothing to no nobody
if you're trying to prove something then
you're being fake about it I just want
to be left alone not get
bullied but it's going to happen it's
it's
inevitable I got so many cases that were
never brought up or never found about or
they just never
just I have so much guilt so much pain I
was
like there's nothing special about me
there is really nothing special about me
I don't gang
bang I'm a I'm a dad and I'm very like
a like a let's say you you're having
we're at the park and we're all together
and the family's together and somebody's
f [__] with our kids I'm the first
one's going to be up there and be like
what the
[__] somebody disrespecting your wife
your auntie and trust and believe I'm
going to have a problem with it trust
and believe I'mma respect your mama
I'mma put out my blunt I'm I'mma put out
my cigarette I'mma not drink around your
mama she don't drink and I expect you to
do the same thing respect the elders I
respect the elders I don't do it because
like my mom would taught me no cuz I
left at
i i i i CU my friends were so much older
that I fell in love with them because
they're my second family my street
family and it's just it's something that
there's something Primal about me to
want to respect
Elders cuz who picks on somebody that's
weak who picks on somebody who's older
we like you some of some of are not are
not weak some are very older and very
still strong and very smart about
getting getting away with the
[__] but I'm never going to pick up make
disrespect the old lady I'm not going to
disrespect you know what I'mma take that
back this lady the other day I'm going
tell you I'm looking into a story this
lady I don't know who the [__] she is
she said something about my
kids she said [__] you and your kids and
she like I know I know and I know about
you I like lady I don't know who the
[__] you are and [__] you about up my
[__] my kids and
[__] she about probably 55 60 Mexican
lady I walked away feeling bad for
saying that but but then it was like no
no no no [__] that this random lady
should [__] started talking [__]
about you and your kids and I told him
you're probably timeing to think about
somebody else and no and know it's you
you're Gonzalez
right man later on that day this [__]
girl she she she pops up
going you need to keep this person's
name out your mouth or cuz we already
know where you where your family lives
at your your your mom your dad [__]
we know we know your
ex I'm like my ex my ex I'm like what
the my my kids are like why you why you
I was like who's this person's name you
know the person's name this is some
drama some drama [__] real on God in
life and this
[__] walks off and I don't know it's
like I don't know I'm not going to say
the the name because I'm not even sure
what name it
is the next day I get [__] raped
which is
today when it was actually uh like at 2
o'clock in the
morning I got
raped for the second time in my life
because I used to ended up being an
escort model and well not a model but
more like a a hooker I'll say hooker
that think the right word for me would
be a
hooker first time they he he tried to
choke me out and [__] beat the [__]
out of me and call me a [__] nasty
piece of [__] [__] I choked them the
[__] out this time around
though I did some
drugs I just smoked
it and for some reason I couldn't
[__]
move I you know I mean I couldn't I [__]
I could barely nudge nudge nudge only I
kept trying to push up push up and and
the most I can go up is probably like
that much of like distance from arm
and I kind like kind of look back a
little bit and there's this guy [__]
just already naked and [__] about to
get on top of me I'm like what the [__]
I was like hey but I can't get out I'm
not I can't get out like hey hey it's
more like stop get off me get out please
get off
me dude and then he he's
like you've died like this so many times
before already
anyways he was high I don't know what
the [__] he's talking
about
there's people passing
by that I kind of hang out with hearing
skid roll and
[__] nobody did crap about
it I never felt so more so alone
again when you ain't got cops helping
you you ain't got the government helping
you you ain't got your family helping
you you ain't got people that said that
guy had your back in your you know who
they like hey I got you whenever you
need and
[__] my mom's not going to get give a
[__] the day that I got shot I called
her and I told her I got shot I got shot
six
times she so what do you
want there's nothing I can do for you
and [__] I was
like that's your problems you got issues
and
[__] I you know and then from there I
had to recover from my bullet wounds on
the streets of skid
R first thing I get shot and I'm trying
to recover on the streets people are
trying to punk me test me push me around
more for some
reason and it it it I didn't understand
that like cuz I don't go walking around
talking [__] to people I I do my
drugs and I try to go get
laid I don't get
it I feel so alone right
now these people they they say I'm
dangerous
I believe they think I'm dangerous cuz
I'm suicidal and when I got shot within
that second I said don't call the
ambulance and when I got stabbed in my
low my juggler I I said Thank God within
those few seconds I swear to you said
Thank God I'm ready to die cuz I've been
so depressed and had I thought a hard
life at that
time sh [__] got really [__] haywired
in these past two three
years I tell people please leave me
alone cuz I am so suicidal I you think
that I have you keep calling me a punk a
[__] okay you can call me that if you
want but if you're going to try to push
me away chase me off the the street
chase me off the block without me just
slowly kind of just walking off I'm not
going to just respect
you I barely walked by and they start
they start talking
[__] what are you doing here who are you
what the
[__] get the [__] out of here I'm not
even doing nothing to
them but I'm trying to figure this [__]
out real
deep and they say it CU I'm
Mexican and they said they said Cu
uh they they said can I try to act too
cocky but my I am so spaced out because
I'm schizophrenic and uh and
major depressive that did I get tunnel
vision I get like I see nothing besides
these Visions in front of my face and
I'm walking so I'm telling you a story
to explain myself to if any if anybody
listens to this this video I am so
spaced out in my own thoughts my own
imaginary [__]
illusions that I'm not trying to Mad Dog
nobody I'm just trying to like
I'm just trying to
survive I love these people out here you
know why cuz they've been through some
hard [__] I've been through some hard
[__] I can relate with
them but it hurts me like when they try
to be
like you [__] you [__] you're
[__] I'm like bro what's going on with
this I'm like who are
you
all this drama it's it's
so it has to be my fault can no CU
there's nobody they could just walk
around and be like automatically have
the whole city of skid ran just start
[__] with them for no
reason I must have [__] up somewhere
down the
line I'm trying to figure it out I'm
pretty sure one day I'll find out what
happened but the only thing I think of
is that when people talk crap to me when
I first got here skid roll I just I
didn't take
it I Roblox I get I started doing the
Roblox I do my stance and like what up
what up I got got beat up other times
they just walked
off but they always come at me when I'm
like
weak I'm I'm being real Petty right now
I'm being real s like like
what about me what about me what about
me what about me because I see a large
community but then I think about man
what about them what about not not damn
as a group but what about that one
person they're having a hard time too
and
[__] what about that person they're
having a hard time too I don't I don't
care if you pulled out the gun on me I
don't care if you told me I was a [__]
ass [__]
Mexican I when I walk away I see [__]
pain I see hurt and I don't blame you
dog I don't blame her
I don't blame
nobody I don't blame any of us for doing
drugs for being on the streets if
anybody else would have been on the
street suit trust and believe you would
want to use drugs
too do do you feel like being on the
streets keeps you
using
I I've been on the streets for so long
rather than coming down here seeing how
terrible it is and say I got to I got to
get away from this lifestyle it's almost
like the trauma of being down here makes
you want to use again
yeah it's very traumatic and I keep
wanting to
use
because I like it here even though it's
it's been rough but the thing is my life
has always been rough so as this this to
me is the norm me being around these
people that are just come we're
sometimes wigging out sometimes we
having a good time sometimes we're way
too high sometimes we're no we don't
have enough
I love this place I love being who I am
I love I like I like the danger I like
the the the the unknown I like meeting
the randomst [__] crazy people or
meeting the most prettiest [__] soul
in the
world that's who who be like will humble
you real quick and slap the [__] at you
with with kind eyes and be still be your
friend these
people I love this
place but it's killing me and [__] [__]
it's killing all of us little by
little but yeah the the being on the
streets is definitely being homeless is
a reason why I do do
drugs is I I I I get scared to go to
sleep on the streets when they when they
got me in the the the
throat I was
asleep I wasn't aware of
anything
I'm such a shitty [__] drug addict
that I had my [__] two kids taken
away I feel so [__] bad that God put
them in my
life because it's not fair for
them doesn't matter how I [__] you
might perceive me or how I look and [__]
I am so cold about [__] as long as
you're breathing
in my in my heart you're okay if you're
hungry and you're crying all this [__]
I'll keep on pushing because you know
what you're okay to me other people like
oh you all right and leave them the [__]
alone they're still breathing they're
all right they're good trust me that's
good that's good enough for me and that
that should be good enough for any of
us and it's
just I don't want to be cold and
[__] I I
cuz either society's trying to tell us
you know something [__] no it's not
about Society it's my
heart when it comes to the girls you got
to be kinder a little bit Kinder I guess
you know
they're some of
them I'm not I I don't know what I'm
trying to get at right now I'm kind of
kind of kind of getting offering I'm
kind of getting foggy in my
head what's your big what's your biggest
fear now my biggest
fear I want to fill out a non
resucitation piece of paper at the
hospital for the next
one I want I want to make sure that if
anything ever happens I get shot again
or I I do commit suicide again that they
they do not res they do not bring me
back I might look happy and I am happy
but but I'm blocking out so much that I
can't even tell you on camera
like and it's like a it's like a major
[__] job get getting clean is not an
option for you it I have uh done about
five
rehabs I just got out another rehab
about 4 days
ago first thing I saw a a pipe within
that second without thought without
remorse without just hey maybe you
shouldn't no it was like let me hit that
pipe real
quick I am such a [__] easy [__]
like tap
out I mean like I mean like tapping out
like with
sobriety because I've been high longer
than I've been sober I've been and
addict for 24
years being being a a male prostitute is
not [__]
exciting dealing with [__] males is a
horrible thing I have to get really
[__] high for me to have to deal with
the
male because I feel
nothing but trust and believe you better
pay up or I'mma [__] you
up well and mean the cops look at me
like did you hit him look at me I was
like
No And the cops I don't think [__] he
would do
it I take I'll take that all the time
these people be like down the street
like he a [__] he ain't G to do [__]
like you're right I won't I never
have I get away with a lot of
[__] and that's when people started
thinking this was dangerous he's
suicidal he has a certain type of look
that he's on he don't do [__] he
wouldn't do nothing
but is your drug methamphetamine for
sure my main my main do my main goal is
methampetamine the high oh that feeling
that o that that just you're uh your
your your hormones get to like a this
level like man I'm about I'm about to
[__] a [__] real good right now and
it's is when you're on meth and you're
having sex it's not just
like when I'm having sex my knee barely
touching your leg or my dig touching
your [__] or my chest when it comes to
females my chest touching touching your
chest it's so euphoric like being on a
good uh like taking triple Stacks like
like the little pills you take out like
AC um ecdc the club the the the Rave
clubs I mean just the slightest brush I
mean I'll come back and forth come over
and over and over again with a female
with the just by just barely touching
her and [__] barely seeing her drop her
[__] panties and get naked I will
come right there her just barely by just
by looking at I get so so so in tune
with them me during that moment that
it's so addictive
cuz this is like your orgasm how many
times in a
night
[__] me about 12 times before before I
start kind of hurting cuz it gets kind
of like my dick's going I don't know if
I can do this anymore more no you
can it gets but
it's I go I I ain't that big but I can
pump that [__] real good I I I had this
girl named Solomon and [__] down here in
skido in my tent for three days straight
never been so much no they for 37 never
been so proud had this [__] [__] me
and her [__] we couldn't even breathe
our throats were so dry we were so
[__] [__] up we couldn't even get
up and go get water down the street we
were about to die from doing way too
much
[__] when we got out that tent
crawling out everybody's like you guys
are way too high he like no we've been
[__] for like three days
straight that smells like [__] in here I
like yeah there's a lot of [__] but
[__] [__] on the goddamn bed and
[__] juice without a [__]
juice crystal meth a hell of a it's a
hell of a drug but you feel like so like
for the guys that you feel like damn I I
get I do I did something right that the
the human body needs to do as a as a
mate when a guy has is a
mate it's it's in us to have like you
know we have to have
sex have then have kids and what not
reproducing as a human race but when you
do that [__] right not like just showing
up to the job you show to the job with
like [__] extra [__] meals for the
for your [__] your your co-workers
you showed her the [__] a little bit
extra [__] like hidden vodka for your
friends and that at work you showed up
and and you did your [__] all you
your
[__] everything you need to do work
and some and your boss is like [__] yeah
thank you bro and that's how it feels
like when I'm I'm on meth having sex
with the girl giving a high five at the
end of the sex she like what the [__]
was that I was like right usually it's
like 10 minutes when I'm sober we went
[__] 3 4 days
straight and I mean that that feel like
[__] I I'm a [__]
beast at least at least I feel like that
did you sleep at all those those three
days no no no we we we we would come go
shower come back to the tent [__] go
shower come back to the tent just cuz I
like me I I like them cllean they got to
be clean because eventually if you have
like of the the female busting it's
going to start smelling kind of funky
same same with the Ms and stuff
like man when you find that right girl
right your type your body type that you
love and she loves you back too the sex
is like [__] art it is pure [__]
art pure human emotion
just [__] religion this is beyond
religions this is like mystical magical
[__] feelings of
just did we just make something happen
somewhere
like what do you she be like what do you
mean I don't know I just felt like we we
became God and god and goddess right now
like I don't think we're supposed to be
[__] like this it's just a feeling
it's just it's stupid I know I know that
that that expression expression is kind
of stupid
but I don't
know I hate my life then I love
it I hate the fact that people throw God
in my life and they bring them
up
I'll bring them
up I
I you know what I'm not going to do that
I I can't I refuse to disrespect
anybody's religion or what they believe
in but I'm
Pagan I'm Pagan because of my grandma
she has the Viking disease the Viking
disease is when the elders only 2% of
the world gets
that's a part of the usually
Scandinavian or like people from uh that
were Viking that that era only 2% of the
elders that had pure blood to be like in
the Viking Vikings or
Scandinavian get it so I'm like cool
grandma was like what's wrong with your
hand I looked it up the second thing
pops up on Google it says how did you
find out you're you're
you're almost pure [__] Viking or
Scandinavian because Vikings lived in
Scandinavia and Vikings were like kind
of like Pirates it it was it was a trade
it was a job so it's I'm like cool cool
grma like we're Viking she's like I
don't give a [__] I don't care I was
like you're Mexican I was like no we're
like this [__] says like we're like more
pure [__] Vikings and Vikings were
like uh brown skin dark dark eyes
Hollywood destroyed that for for a lot
of people and confus
this they said they were blonde blueeyed
I'm like
man I I like man from there I started
studying other things like what else did
America lie to us to what what else did
the T TV shows Li lie to us about what
what who else is lying you know it's
just I don't trust people I don't trust
what people post I don't I don't even
trust the [__] that I'm saying to you
right now I don't trust it I feel like
I'm lying but I'm
not but then it feels like who you
trying to prove I'm not trying to prove
to nobody [__] I'm telling you what that
has actually happened in my life but I'm
not going to tell you the story point to
point to point to point to point cuz I
don't want you to go on a
timeline and try to be like oh this is
why he's doing like this at this moment
or why just because I'm feel I feel like
the da or [__] prosecutors going to
be like okay let's send this video to
somebody that's my paranoia my my
paranoia schizophr of
paranoia I'm so paranoid dog but
paranoia kep paranoia kept me alive and
paranoid probably probably [__] got
me to you know I think that's why might
be my paranoia probably makes other
people think that I'm doing something
wrong
[__] and it makes s out man you know
what the you're being paranoid as [__]
what you do because that's what I do
when someone is paranoid around me I'm
like what the [__] your problem what'
you do I get away from me like oh man
you know what in this [__] moment
this second right now during this
interview I just figured out why the
[__] some of these people hate me cuz I
be right as [__] from the crystal meth
cuz the crystal meth but I've been
stabbed jumped cuz I broke my jaw I've
been shot six times I've been I've been
raped I I mean it's uh I grew up in a
very abusive uh childhood left had
nobody teach me [__] I had at the age of
16 I trusted everybody and got ripped
off by
everybody you know I how many days you
been without sleep today three 3 days I
haven't I haven't slept it's been
raining for 3 days
straight I tried to get into the
Midnight Mission they kept telling me to
come back the next day the next day
today today I was supposed to go to the
the LA uh the to the grant the Grant
hotel right it's the fight the the five
star hotel that they're helping out the
homeless with LA gr I showed up first
thing I get there some guy standing
there says oh this fo's loud as [__]
he's he's going to cause US
problems I'm like I was like who are I
was like who I was like who are you and
[__] I was like who are you and you I
was like I started crying [__] cuz I was
like I was already having a bad day I
was you know [__] this
[__] so instead of staying at the grant
right now in a king-sized bed my own
room my own shower I walked away because
of my pride being you know what [__]
this guy right now you he's he's already
talking [__] about me I'm not going to
deal with it I'm GNA walk away from
it but that's what I do here and too
with like when I walk around someone
talk [__] I'll go to the next spot
someone talk [__] then I'll go to the
next spot someone talk [__] then I go to
the next
spot
that's it's it's it's it's interesting I
I might have some uh dealing issues with
uh with coping with negative words from
people I wish I was more of a man more
more of a collective man that could be
like I understand you
know I understand sometimes I get it
sometimes I
don't but
George what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life the most important important lesson
I've learned
right after uh dying from the suicide
and from getting
shot bro you need to if you want to even
try to do this you need to love
yourself whether if you want to be a
trans write on for you brother if you
want to be a trans that's cool as [__]
cuz I got friends that are trans and
that's dope you know what I got you're
cool as [__] you're being you you want
to be happy that's that's what makes you
feel sexy or empowering do do so if
you're if you're a female and you want
to dress up be all pretty and like have
a little skimpy ass shorts do so if you
want to feel sexy and feel good do so me
if I want to work out and have a decent
Siz like chest and and tight like good
kind of dressed up for the day even
though I'm broke and homeless on the
street I will do so be happy with you if
you're gay he say you gay cool or
actually you don't have to do that you
don't have to tell people hey I'm gay
just be happy I don't walk around and
telling people I'm bye I I just I am who
I am if I want to have [__] pink
nails I will if I don't if I want to
wear a [__] like camouflage Sho I
will if I want wear Dickies I will other
days I got hurly little like little
shorts and [__] and I have like a decent
like little haircut and [__] cuz I do it
for me not not for nobody else no more I
don't do it for no [__] I don't do it
for for no no no I don't do it for no no
no scene no
crowd I do it cuz George deserves me
George deserves to be a little bit happy
I might not be
rich but godamn I feel good when I get
dressed up and I'm high as [__] I feel
cocky and sexy and [__] handsome at
the same
time my my full day is wake up get drugs
get cleaned up go get laid other people
want to get up get mad deal with what's
going on up and down the block with some
of those people's [__] [__] that
when you tell me hey like hey this I
don't like this about this I I don't
like about this and I'll be like I'll
cut I'll cut him off real quick hey you
thought about getting
late so sometimes they get mad and
sometimes they like you know yeah you
know you're right and I probably yeah
yeah they'll conf get all confused it
went from Mad to like I need some [__]
yeah brother like we all need a [__]
every every day you wake up think about
hey let's try to get cleaned up and get
some [__] it's not we're not going to
get it all the time but it's better than
getting up and trying to like control
the whole city control the whole block
control your friends and [__] like bro
control your happy or down there your
[__] goddamn dick and get your
satisfaction in that level that sh cuz
that there's nothing better than sex and
drugs [__] being high and [__] trying
to rule all right George let's finish
this out on that that's a great way to
finish it thank you very much yeah
thanks